scores of people came to this church to
attend bars
the attackers came to kill as many as
they could
those who got out came under Fire
outside
it's quite unbelievable that somebody
will come and the intention was to kill
everybody in that church
those are running out they were being
shot from outside those who were inside
were being shot from inside
the true two dynamons to blow up the
altar down to the sanctuary
this kind of the secretion is can only
be done by the evil one
medical workers fear some of the Wounded
may not survive
they are appealing for help
not for them as many people that are
within the hospital environment should
come and please assist
Nigeria's president muhammadu buhari and
the understate governor have condemned
the attack saying those responsible will
be brought to Justice
what a surprise many is the location of
the massacre the southwest of Nigeria
suffered little of the violence sweeping
the North and the East attacks have
killed tens of thousands and displaced
hundreds of thousands more in those
regions during the last 10 years
Security Services have struggled to
contain the violence
Nigeria is due to hold general elections
early next year but with the violence
spreading concerns are growing where the
polling can be held in areas worst
affected by these attacks Ahmed Idris Al
Jazeera Abuja Nigeria